know what the thing about this today is
pot marijuana's been in so much in the
news the last couple of years and it's
becoming legalized
for
for as long as i can remember you have
been the ambassador to pot you have been
interested in getting people to accept
pot you've been interested in getting
celebrities into pot
uh i heard that you got if it's true
that you got martha stewart
high at the justin bieber roast is that
true
well
i blew a couple of shotguns in her
direction
you blew some shotguns her way and you
think it had an effect yeah i believe
that she got hit by uh some
miscellaneous smoke yeah
did you see her relax did you see her
attitude change oh yeah she was mellow
she was really you know really about it
after she got her mind right yeah
okay what about you're apparently really
good pals with larry king yeah have you
gotten high with larry king well you
know larry's up there in age so i just
had to make sure that he didn't you know
fall out so i wanted to make sure that i
could you know sprinkle larry with the
game right so
you're saying you eased larry king
uh into a little bit of weed you eased
him into it a little bit he didn't want
him to fall out you mean die yeah yeah
yeah
so what did you do you just put a little
bit of it on his pudding what did you do
well you know he had like you know small
little you know prune juice and we had a
little mix with them
you spiked larry king's prune juice
that's fantastic
[Applause]
snoop
snoop what's happening
it's like a three stooges yeah it's
ridiculous snoop you've known me a long
time uh you've never done that with me
do you think i would react well you
think how do you think i'd handle it i
think it would have to be after the show
yeah and what i what i decided to do was
i built a green room for you today that
you can you know pop in
you know and pop in and out and see if
you feel like feeling like you know the
feeling
you say a green room what are you
talking about now
usually we learned a long time ago not
to give you a green room
backstage like everyone else because
things filter through the system yeah
and other guests get high yeah
so we've given you your own space your
own trailer
tonight today and you're saying that i
could go there after the show please
come on please
and just chill out
you're more than welcome as well i need
to thank you guys and you can bring the
band
the band's already been in there
you uh you know what's funny uh i i
learned this today you actually because
in order to smoke you need a
prescription yes to smoke pot you have a
prescription
what is your ailment that what is what
is snoop dogg's ailment technically that
that helps you that gives you a
prescription
migraines and back pains
they always have to rhyme yeah when was
that
yeah convenient they rhymed when was the
last time you experienced either a
migraine or a back pain uh my back
hurting right now
okay
snoop i didn't realize you have an alter
ego that you have posted online and it's
a character you do called todd should we
show the video first and then at talk
about todd yeah show the video okay take
a look this is todd shout out to
everyone out there having fun today
it's a fun day for you fun guys who have
fun
life's full of fun i'm fun
you should be fun too
so says todd
[Applause]
yeah you're definitely going to see more
time